the fate of the multiverse
depends on us
a new tv spot with a lot of new footage
and voice lines from doctor strange and
a multiverse of madness has just
released so let's break it down so the
tv spot starts off with doctor strange
saying the multiverse it's life or death
the footage shown here we have pretty
much seen before apart from a new angle
of wonder and doctor strange walk in and
an extended shot moving on we have
doctor strange and wonder having a
conversation where doctor strange is
saying they could use another avenger
one who doesn't seem to be too
interested as she says there are other
avengers doctor strange then makes a
joke saying or get you back in her
lunchbox meaning that if she helps
doctor strange her reputation will be
restored in the public eye but then this
cuts to a new shot of wonder where she
is seen attacking something now i
believe this is from the sequence we
have seen previously in the trailers
where doctor strange and wong have been
attacked by this mysterious person and i
believe this mysterious person is no
other than wonder herself moving on we
have new footage of mordo where he is
seen attacking doctor strange he twirls
the dagger and then goes in for a strike
against doctor strange but then he
erades out of the way this then
transitions to a scene of a mysterious
character now people speculate and this
could be superior iron man but to be
honest i don't think it is but let me
know what you guys think in the comment
section below is this superior iron man
or is it someone else we then cut to
some new footage and a new voice line by
wong where he says the fate of the
multiverse depends on us now what's very
interesting about this new footage is
that it seems like wonder is teaming up
with wong now in the previous trailer it
seems like um wonder was marketed to be
the villain of the film now seems like
she may be helping them at one point in
the film so i got a little bit of a
prediction perhaps in this scene
particularly a bigger threat comes into
play which is more powerful than both of
them so if wonder and wong won't have a
fight and chance to survive then they
both have to team up to fight whatever
they're facing then perhaps once they
have defeated it they'll go back to
fighting against each other or maybe
once they defeat together they'll
actually stay as allies for the rest of
the film i guess only time will tell in
response to wong's dialogue we have
doctor strange saying no pressure then a
cool new shot of doctor strange stepping
on top of a taxi now i believe this
scene is from the street battle where
they fight gangan toss what i think has
happened is that doctor strange has been
flung into this building behind him and
then it recovers and then emerges out
from the building and steps onto the
taxi now what makes me think this is
definitely the street scene is that in
the background of the street scene
battle you can see um a little bit of a
taxi and a green pillar in the
background so if we go back to new
footage we can see that same green
pillar and that taxi then the end of the
trailer confirms that tickets will be
gone on sale april 6 wednesday but apart
from that that is all of the new footage
from this tv sport so i hope you guys
enjoyed and if you did please like and
subscribe if you haven't already and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching